بالفعل هو يوم تاريخي بامتياز ان يدان
رئيس امريكي في محكمه الجنايات هنا في
منهات الخلفي وسط تغطيه عالميه غير مسبوقه
طبعا قبل قليل بدات المؤيدين والمعارضين
يتفاوضون على هذه النقطه بالتحديد لكن
بالعشرات ليس بالمئات وليس بالالاف كما
نتوقع طبعا الشرطه موجوده في كل زاويه
محيطه في هذه المحكمه وايضا تم اغلاق كل
الشوارع المؤديه اليها نتوقع وننتظر وصول
الرئيس ترامب طبعا لن نراه لانه سادخل من
باب خلفي وطبعا سيتم اخذ بصماته وسنعرف
لاول مره ونترقب معا الاعلام الامريكي
ونحن والعالم ما هي هذه التهم نتوقع ان
تكون اكثر من 30 تهمه واحده على الاقل قد
ترتقي الى جنايه وبالتالي سنرى اذا كان
القاضي يرى بان هذه الادله قويه
محكمه ام انه يمكن ان يغلق الملف تماما
قبل قليل ايضا راينا نائبين يحسبان على
اليمين المتطرف وهو
الى هنا وكان البعض يلاحقهم يعني
المتظاهرين ضد الرئيس ترامب يلاحقونهم
ويحاولون ابعادهم عن المحكمه لكن بشكل عام
الاجواء هادئه وجود الشرطه يمنع اي احتكاك
بين الطرفين لا احد يتوقع اعمال عنف على
الاطلاق اولا لان الرئيس ترامب لم يدعوا
انصاره للوفود هنا بعشرات الالاف كما
راينا في احداث الكافيتال في واشنطن وفي
ذلك الوقت المقرر ربما غير سليمه لانه
الرئيس كان يريد ان يقلب نتائج الانتخابات
بينما اليوم يحاكم على الاقل بسبب دفع
اموال لممثله اباحيه